good morning Millennials why do you say
it like that what do I say it like you
say it
like feel like CU you're trying to also
sing it and say it you know no I think
it's because of this family reference of
good morning and G it is gud yeah yeah
yeah but but you're saying it okay this
is so deep but when we went to high
school remember when we went to high
school when we went to our first High
School yep yeah good morning do you know
that somebody it's I I will literally
show you the text after but somebody
referenced that to me like two weeks ago
swear to God and you're going to cry
from the reference but um yes I know
exactly what you're talking about okay
let's just explain it to the listeners
because this is so inside baseball but
Olivia and I went to high school
together I mean our whole Liv but we
went to two different high schools which
is why I'm being so weird about high
school high school the first high school
that we went to which we loved the
principal used to make an announcement
over the speaker every morning and he
would always say
good morning and he said like that he
said it weird and that's how you're
saying it no I'm saying it because I
feel like honestly that is not what was
at the Forefront of my mind what was is
I feel like good morning Millennials is
G you with two dots over a d and so like
I say it like that and sing it like that
because I feel like that's what you guys
do like I'm trying to emulate Claudia in
the seat yeah I feel like the way that I
said is good yeah I say with a like go D
good morning millennium
is no that's horrible no that's why I'm
doing good morning you know oh I'm
realizing that you're focusing on the
word morning for me and I'm focusing on
good is that the word that is is no it
was all weird
but but it's fine you bring your own
flare to the show it's morning you know
you bring your own flare to the show and
we're so excited to have you here happy
Friday everyone so little bit change of
plans I was supposed to podcast with
Claudia today from Diva Las Vegas but
she had a wild night out with the Bravo
swirlies so she asked me to podcast
without her so Olivia is joining me for
this audio only episode we're in my
studio recording which is really fun
because we're not doing video we're like
not looking at a camera we're looking at
each other and it's very intimate it's
very intimate and I it's definitely like
less pressure you know I feel I do feel
a bit more comfortable I have to be
honest like being in the podcast only
format because obviously podcasting like
alone on its own is just so you you
realize why people really open up on
podcast cuz you could like not when we
do video but like see how I'm sitting
spre I'm in my sweats like I'm cozy you
just never know what's going to be
shared 100% yeah Audio Only is a is a
special kind of episode yeah and it's
perfect for Friday perfect for Friday
energ I needed we don't have Claudia
here to sing us into the day but we do
have Olivia do you have a song that you
want to sing today um you know that I
don't watch the toast every single day
although deep in my heart I'm the number
one fan so like explain to me what
singing into the day even means Friday
you know she sings every time she intros
a Friday episode she sings her the song
which you know I got to get down on
Friday yeah so like you could sing that
you could sing anything really whenever
I think of Youth singing do you know
what I think of um do you think about
Belle Beauty and the Beast or do you
think about Only Hope Mandy Moore oh
that's a good one too no those are the
only two songs that I sing I think of
little town it's a quiet Village
beautiful keep going every day like the
one
before you know it's so funny people
don't know that in our eighth grade
production um I was Bell and Beauty and
the Beast and so I know that movie
forwards and backwards that play
actually cuz you know it's such a fun
fact Olivia was the star of the Middle
School play she was Belle uh I think I
was a village person just supporting my
big sis on stage was like super in into
theater music the whole shebang in high
school Claudia and I were in choir
together and they never gave us solos so
we quit um but we were we were you know
we talked about this last time like
we're musical girlies playing
instruments doing drama yeah chorus so
one of Kayla's favorite movies is Beauty
and the Beast and does she know yet that
her mother starred as Belle um we like
tell her but she doesn't she's like what
are you talking about we need to find
like the VHS if anybody went to our
Middle School has I feel like I know a
way to get it really yeah yeah I'll work
on it I'll work on it oh my God that
would be so funny there's only like that
one iconic picture where my hair is like
super curly and you were like an extra
on a village person yeah yeah what was
your play on the roof
yeah Fiddler on the Roof slaps the music
Bops if you haven't ever seen it watch
it combat anti-Semitism watch Fiddler on
the Roof this weekend I love that we
need to add that to our list of movies
for family vacation Claud and I have a
running list of movies that we think
would be good for the whole family to
watch that we can pull up the list when
we're on vacation and we have we don't
know what to watch um which always
happens so I'm going to add Fiddler on
the Roof Fiddler on the Roof o Matilda
have you seen that on Netflix yet is
there a new one there's a Matilda the
Musical no haven't seen I think it came
I don't know if it came out yet but
they've been like working on it for a
while and it looked really good I'm
watching Bosch like that's my vibe you
know no what's that oh it's
um you know like drama cop drama murder
mystery Vibes you know oh that's so you
so me cool but there's a new season and
it's on freey which is like the Amazon
ad supported um which is super annoying
but got to do what you got to do at
least it's free V free V yeah that's an
interesting t I don't mind it yeah I
mean it's annoying it's literally cable
no I know but it's like annoying when
you actually think about it because I'm
watching it on Amazon Prime which I pay
for right so it's like and then I'm
getting this like ad like I'm
intentionally paying for the service
like I pay for 15 other services so my
goal would be to watch something without
freaking ads but I think you can watch
freebie without paying for Amazon Prime
is the point oh I know but but you're
already paying yeah I hear you that's
where I'm accessing it no if you're
going to not pay for something and
you're going to get commercials like so
it's so we're back to what we left yeah
honestly though it's not like six ads
there's two okay they're like 90
seconds yeah and they only come up two
times instead of like every 15 minutes
if you're watching like an hourong
program listen everyone's trying to make
it work everyone's trying different
things of AD supported subscription
based I don't know where things are
going to shake out but they're trying
their best they're trying their best and
they're using us as the guinea pigs yeah
we are the product
that's like in the social dilemma when
it's like if you're not paying for
something you're the product
y serious
stuff well I'm excited to have you on
the show today you're going to help me
break down the fast five stories that
you need to know anything new with you
that you want to share with everyone any
anecdotes
thoughts not really it's just been like
another Whirlwind of a week I feel like
I can't even believe it's Friday already
and I'm so glad it is I'm super ready
for the weekend we're just getting over
Levi having hand foot mouth which was a
real journey um and yeah I'm just um
cheers to the freaking weekend cheers to
the freaking weekend and I guess I
should mention it would be on Claudia to
mention this um she didn't mention it
all week and now she's not here today so
I I guess I'll have to you know talk
about myself that my birthday's on
Monday yeah so the next time you guys
hear from me I will be a year older a
year wiser and that's just weird this is
like such a crazy birthday I've never
never been like less prepared for a
birthday like it's just how old are you
31 I'll be turning I thought you were
turning 30 actually like I just only
realize that you're 31 cuz I'm 32 and I
know there's a year part between us so
yeah yeah 31 it's like you know what 31
is just like a whatever birthday you
know yeah sometimes when I think about
it I'm like whoa I'm not going in that
Lake that's really old but other times
no you're already 30 what's the
difference between 30 and 31 aged and
I'm the youngest in my friend group so
like they're all turning 32 and it's
like oh I'm not even 31 yet oh okay cool
you're so young I'm just so young it's
your birthday we'll we'll have some
celebrations this weekend we were just
talking about what we're going to do I
think it's going to be a chili birthday
I just want to like make a chili have
you guys over chill chili birthday yeah
but um I'm going to make a chili because
those are the best days got chili on the
stove you guys will come we'll have
dinner together and Monday night you can
watch some football true that sounds
like just what I'm looking for right now
I'm just extremely tired and I just want
to chillax so that's all I'm looking for
for for my birthday love that for you
great well I guess without further Ado
we could get into everything we have a
lot to do today and I know you're a busy
woman as are you true so I don't want to
keep you got to make our dinner tonight
oh my gosh I'm making beef stew thank
you for reminding me cuz Claudia does
not care about my beef stew Journey just
wait in two years she'll be like I'm
making beef stew but you know I care
deeply you care deeply also because you
are going to be enjoying my beef stew
tonight I am and I'm sure it's going to
be absolutely delicious so I made it
last week when Dana was here and it was
really good but I'm not following that
recipe again I didn't think it was
enough food and not enough flavor if I'm
being honest like New York Times do
better [__] so right now I'm looking
for the right recipe for us I think I
might have found it oh but I think also
you know mymo is just like wing it you
can't mess it up you'll be fine but
that's no no no no that's where you and
I differ okay I found a recipe from
spend with pennies I made her ma mashed
potatoes once before so I kind of trust
her and this one has celery it has
carrots potatoes onions which the other
one did and it has celery and peas I
don't want peas do you like peas I do
okay I could add them I just always find
that they're the only thing left on my
plate you know I eat around them oh well
maybe that's a you thing but Zach had
also said it would be good with peas so
fine I'll add the peas and it gives like
shepherd's pie Vibes you know yeah I
wanted to add mushrooms lovely I love a
mushroom okay it's just if it's not in
the recipe like when do I put it in I
really need it to be like paint by
numbers you know yeah you'll be fine I
don't know Olivia what do you think is
going to happen to the mushrooms the
mushrooms will be overcooked or
undercooked they'll disintegrate okay or
they'll be tough and chewy but mushrooms
like have umph to them like a carrot
think about that like you're not going
to cook a carrot to such high hell that
it turns into puree in your stew no but
a carrot starts very hard it's not the
same texture they should need the same
amount of time there's a lot of moisture
in a mushroom I think you'll be okay
okay I'm going to have to just dress my
gut I would sauté the mushrooms first so
that way you cook them and then add them
in when you're feeling like it sound off
in the comments what should I do about
the mushrooms thank you welcome but yes
I'm excited and I'm going to bake some H
that I braided last night a lovely
Shabbat you love saying H now I love H
but you don't say Hala anymore I just
say h do I yeah okay um but we haven't
had a meal together actually like in a
bit because Levi had everyone's been
sick yeah it's just been like a rotating
door so now we're MTH is I like really
one of the worst out there for the kids
yeah but it's like okay in the sense of
like it's going to be okay it's going to
be okay there's nothing to give there's
nothing to give them which makes it like
a good one and a bad one right like
there's nothing to give them because
it's kind of the thing that just goes
away on its own needs time but there's
really very limited things you can do
for your child to make them feel better
because you like you know it's not like
ear infection antibiotic okay you know
that there's a process for that and it
took about like really 10 days for
everything to just go away completely
yeah um and he was just in so much pain
because he had the swords in his mouth
he couldn't eat he couldn't sleep um
popsicles like really just saved the day
for him just to like numb his mouth and
like get something down but my sweet boy
it missed his birthday he got sick
literally two days later and the last
time I was on the toast was on his
birthday so it's like just been that's
when you're like what have you been up
to like I've been dealing with Tampa
mouth got it also everyone wanted to
know what I did wind up getting you for
Levi's birthday because I didn't get you
what you thought I got you I got her a
car seat for their golf cart it's hard
with the golf cart with like the little
kid cuz they don't have the seat belt
sometimes and so like you don't want to
hold them so there was this company that
makes like golf cart car seats where you
can strap them in really easily and
that's what I got for Levi cuz he loves
cruising on the go cruising and I had
had a golf cart car seat for Michaela
and the one that you got you guys didn't
like it 4,000 thousand times better like
Z was like okay we're going to actually
buy another one for Michaela cuz they
actually both sit right there you can
have like three of them on the bench
basically somebody driving and the two
kids and they live to drive around in it
like with the wind in their hair it's
their absolute favorite thing yeah cuz I
remember you weren't happy with the one
that you got from Micha and then I found
this one I thought it was really good so
I got one for Lee yeah and you know what
cuz there were very limited options when
I bought it two years ago you know no
it's okay it's not like no no I love it
I'm obsessed and obviously shout out
easygo because we love our golf carts
it's like the best thing ever thanks
Easy Go um okay well now it's time for
the fast five stories and before we get
into said fast five stories I need to
let you know that today's episode of the
toast is brought to you by the new
L'Oreal Paris bright revealed dark spot
serum and broadspectrum SPF 50 daily
lotion dark spots game over so we've
been talking about this um dark spot
serum and Broad SPF daily lotion for a
few weeks now on the toast I actually
was just on the toast Instagram last
night showing you guys how I use the
dark spot serum because dark spots they
got to go summer is over and now you
might be noticing more Spong spots that
you endured from the summer you know fun
in the sun playing pickle ball it's all
fun in games until the dark spots appear
so the dark spot Serum is amazing it has
12% niacinamide amino sulfonic ferulic
acid you don't need to know what those
ingredients do you just need to know
that they work they visibly fade all
types of dark spots such as age spots
and sunspots as well as post acne marks
in a clinical study over 12 weeks expert
grading of dark spots age and sunspots
and postacne marks visibly faded up to
40% which is amazing it's made for all
skin tones suitable for sensitive skin
like our girly here and formulate the
formula is validated by dermatologists
you always want to have a dermatologist
recommended skin product because it's
your skin so L'Oreal is a brand we can
trust these products are amazing I love
the dark spot serum and then the
mornings I add the SPF now that we are
still in the sun you still need SPF so
you can get the duo the bright revealed
dark spot Duo if you visit Target online
and in store to buy yours today when you
pair these two together the Derm valid
Duo visibly red reduces the look of dark
spots in just one week and visibly Fades
and protects from dark spots so this is
a no-brainer head over to Target check
it out the bright reveal dark spot Duo
today's episode is also brought to you
by well Pro so well professionals has
over
140 years of experience developing Hair
Care initially for professional use only
and previously only sold in salons and
consistently ranked among the top loved
Brands by professionals and stylists so
we have been using the Wella ultimate
repair Miracle Hair rescue it's a
leave-in spray treatment design to work
on wet hair if you were to smell my hair
right now you'd say Jax your hair smells
so good and I would tell you it's
because I used my Wella last night I am
obsessed with using it after I wash my
hair so it's a leave-in treatment you do
like 10 to 20 sprays so you just like
lather it all up and actually when Claud
and I were doing our brisket Cookoff
that night we both like stunk like
brisket and so I got in the shower
washed my hair and I sprayed Wella in my
hair and like my hair smelled so good
the next day Claudia was like my hair
still smells like brisket I was like my
hair smells amazing because I love the
Wella um Ultra prepare Miracle Hair
rescue I love a leave-in treatment I
love a leave-in treatment that you don't
have to wash out this is a major key so
the Wella products are amazing they're
used by professionals I don't have that
much time to focus on my hair right now
so I need something that's going to be
90 seconds spray it in leave it in move
on with my life you can try the ultimate
repair Miracle Hair rescue with 10% off
of the travel size on Amazon using promo
code 10 toast so 10% off the travel size
on Amazon by using promo code 10 toast
I'm seriously obsessed with the well a
professionals new line the ultimate
repair line it's the most premium line
to date and it was developed with 140
plus years of experience in research to
deliver the very best
Miracle Hair rescue repairs hair in only
90 seconds has key ingredients Aha and
Omega 9 rebuilds the hair bonds inside
the strands and replenishes the outside
barrier of damaged hair love that for us
don't you yeah I love the ads on the
toast like such relevant brands that
people use that you guys use Beauty
wellness fabulousness it's so true so
wonderful I've got one more for you
today's episode is brought to you by
State Farm the State Farm personal price
plan helps you create an affordable just
for you the plan's all about being
personal to you and your needs that
means you get the coverage you want a
policy that helps cover what's important
to you at an affordable price just for
you because like after all life is just
better when you can personalize your
experiences so you have to think about
it like this like we are all so
different you think we're the same but
we're so different different coffee
order different hair care different
needs you know different in content that
we're into even so of course our
insurance needs to be personal ized just
as well because personalization just
makes everything that much better State
Farm believes Insurance should work the
same way your plan your coverage your
selections can all be personalized by
you so like a good neighbor State Farm
is there prices may vary by state
options selected by customer
availability and eligibility may vary do
you want to give the jingle a was to say
that should have been the song that we
sung into on Friday oh LOL like a good
neighbor State Farm is there like a Good
Neighbor Belle from her eighth grade
musical is there is here at the toast
she is so thank you to our wonderful
sponsors for allowing us to get into the
fast five
stories first story a little Florida
news for your Florida girlies oo Jeff
Bezos announces he's relocating from
Seattle to Miami he said it's an
emotional decision so Jeff Bezos the
founder of Amazon obviously announced
that he is leaving Seattle which has
been his home since 1994 when he started
Amazon out of his garage and where he
built up Amazon and he is moving to uh
to Florida to Miami he said his parents
they recently moved back to Miami it's
the place where he lived when he was
younger he went to high school in Miami
where on the morning speaker they said
good
morning um he explained the motivations
behind his upcoming move he said I want
to be close to my parents and Lauren and
I love Miami he also added that his
space company blue Arin operations are
increasingly shifting to Cape Canaveral
so they are moving on down I just do not
see a Miss Lauren Sanchez in Seattle so
like this makes a lot of sense I did not
realize that they lived in Seattle like
I feel like they don't actually like
when I see pictures of them they're
always like bopping everywhere like that
might be where his like main home is
like he might file taxes in Seattle but
or Washington State I guess but like
regardless I don't think they're
spending a majority of their time there
no for sure well if he files taxes there
he has to spend 180 days there but yeah
know and that's why he's probably making
some move to Florida she's not with him
like she's still back in La no they're
in La yeah 100% I this tracks on so many
levels but also I do think it is this
tracks regardless of knowing that he
grew up in Miami and his parents are
here and but that also is just a
wonderful sentiment you know I'm all for
people being close to their family so um
literally Florida is the place to be
it's the place to be you think like
maybe we'll have a casual runin with
Jeff Bezos oh I don't know I feel like
they'll always be like on a boat you
know totally you're never getting never
getting on a boat we'd have to like you
know sail the Seas looking for them yeah
yeah but I think that's good for the
state great for the state right that
would be good for the state that brings
like a lot of wealth into the state yep
yep I guess there's a very like
proficient Amazon operation here in the
State of Florida as well like do you
always see the Amazon trucks there's
like seven of them yeah they're fleets
you can order stuff and you get it
literally overnight delivery like it
never had that in New York yeah that's
very true um so hopefully he'll be able
to work here successfully but he like
doesn't I don't think he's really
involved with Amazon you don't I think
yes and no but like he's not the CEO of
the company anymore he's not no Andy
jasse is he stepped down I think he's
probably still the chairman but he's not
the CEO he's not running he's not taping
up my packages and shipping them out no
he's not he's not dayto day at Amazon
anymore oh I didn't realize that oh yeah
so what's his dayto day like obviously
going to the Moon oh right blue origin
and Washington POS he absolutely has
Sanchez I think runs like the Bezos
Earth fund or something like that they
have a I just started following her on
Instagram because I wanted to know what
she's about like what is she stand for
what does she care about it's a lot of
Clean Water stuff you know I have no
idea what she stands for and what she's
about other than her being with Jeff
Bezos is obviously the best thing to
ever happened to her and like the crew
that she runs with is like yeah she's
having a good time she's enjoying she
living her best life and honestly good
for her yeah she's really grown on me um
and I just feel like clean water like
offends although regardless I take back
what I said Justice for McKenzie Bezos
no she's fine yeah like she's fine she
got married and divorced again right
yeah um she's like the richest woman in
the world I'm I don't worry for her yeah
and she's like giving away like all of
her money anyway right the giving pledge
The Giving Tree yeah The Giving Tree I
love that yeah um but you know honestly
like despite the start of this
relationship it actually seems to really
be a viable one yeah no like they're
really going the distance and now
they're engaged like it's very
traditional they dated for a few years
it's like Choy as hell so chy and I no
I'm telling you like I've really turned
a corner yeah the proof is in the
pudding yeah they wanted to prove
everybody wrong and they did yeah happy
for them yeah and they're just like
enjoying their life which is all you can
really hope for from Life 1,000%
especially like when you're that wealthy
it's like if you're not enjoying
yourself really what's what the [__] are
you doing yeah if you're not on your
boat doing God knows what what are you
doing yeah so go to the Moon he had
purchased a seven-bedroom mansion on a
small private island is he living on
that island that everybody lives on
biscane Bay is that in Florida yes it is
okay that's where he had bought a
mansion but he also purchased a
neighboring home um for 1.8 Acres so I
guess that's where they'll live for now
who knows it's probably like a starter
home Jeff BOS
yeah so that's exciting wel welcome to
Florida the Sunshine State party in the
city where the heat is on all night on
the beach till the break of dawn welcome
to Miami Benito Amy I'm so excited for
them yeah me too I defin we should bring
over a casserole we should bring a beef
stew and a holly oh my God we should
bring a beef stew and a holly yeah far
sh so our next Story one of our favorite
girls sorry you've been saying so many
things that I've really like you feel I
mean if you're going to take over for
Claudia feel free to call me out you you
didn't say sunspots you said Spong spots
um but okay well I'm like a new mama so
I have like by the way that's why I
didn't call you out so by the way it's
very real if you don't want to support
new mothers you could call me out sure
oh my God stop it um story our Second
Story our Second Story is about our
favorite girl Jessica Simpson she's
celebrating 6 years of sobriety so
Jessica Simpson is celebrating the
latest milestone in her sobriety Journey
this month she marks 6 years sober the
mother of three celebrated her Milestone
with an Instagram story on Thursday that
linked to a post of a picture of her
from 6 years ago she wrote six years ago
um the original post was in celebration
of her fourth anniversary she's seen
sitting with a Sunbeam lighting up her
face it said the person in the early
morning of November 2017 is an
unrecognizable version of myself I had
so much self-discovery to unlock and
explore I knew in this very moment I
would allow myself to take back my light
show victory over my internal Battle of
self-respect and brave this world with
piercing Clarity she said that a she to
achieve those goals she needed to stop
drinking alcohol I live for Jessica
Simpson live for her and I love that
she's another one just living her best
life like she owns her company again she
has a beautiful family she's feeling
good about herself I just want nothing
but good things for Jessica Simpson I
and 6 years is incredibly like it it's
incredible regardless if you have one
day sober let alone 6 years but honestly
I'm just so happy for her that I I can
tell from her content that she's in a
good place for sure I feel like I ask
you this every time you're on the show
um and I think I know the answer but did
you read her book yes you yes I I read
her book I Lov it okay I thought you
didn't no I we talked about how I read
her book and that I would definitely be
reading Britney's because I like that
genre of book I haven't yet gotten to
Britney's I saw that Britney made the
New York Times best seller list though
so kudos to Britney course but also did
you see the bigger news that her book
was chosen for the redheads no oh that's
amazing okay maybe I'll read with the
group and listen you got to get it's
never too late to become a redhead so
this next book's choice is Dana's choice
so it's crazy that she chose Britney but
she was like honestly I want to read it
should I guess appear on the redheads
this month oh my God yeah you could like
give a little synopsis we've done we've
had no I'm it's definitely like top of
my list to read
and I love a celebrity Memoir yeah as do
I especially celebrities that just
really had such a profound impact on us
growing up like they were our whole
lives you know their music their clothes
their everything they did reading j14
magazine like we didn't have the
internet we were like seeing all these
pcks of them you know living their best
lives but then we now know they weren't
yeah and that has so much you know such
an impact on like who we are what we saw
what our role models were and then to
know what they were going through you
know very interesting I'm I'm fascinated
by all of it right so I'm excited for
Britney for the redheads and for Jessica
Simpson six years soers no small feet
and if you read her book you know like
how how hard of a place she was in what
a tough spot she was in so I'm really
I'm happy for her I'm proud of her me
too very much so and honestly I just
feel like she always has been a like
somebody that so many girls and women
looked up to and I feel like this is
just a whole other way for her be that
for so many people cuz she's now
businesswoman Mom she's sober like do
you know what I mean like there's so
many ways for people to connect with her
no matter where they are in their
Journey not just like pop star actress
Daisy Dukes yeah for sure well our next
story is some Bravo drama Bravo's been
in the news all week that Variety
article came out Bravo Kan is this
weekend was it variety or Vanity
Fair the one the expose Vanity Fair
maybe yeah yeah I started reading it but
it was really long I know I read like
half maybe not even half of it too
there's been some Fallout from the
article um but also it's come out that
the latest installment of the Real
Housewives ultimate girls trip might not
air might be pulled due to the sexual
assault Scandal so Camille gramar was on
that season and she commented she said
what a shame it's a reality show I saw a
few Clips it's very funny I didn't see
anything that crazy while filming that I
have not seen before over the years so
Camille was on that installment along
with Brandy Glenville Vicky gumson
Gretchen Rossy fedra Parks Eva Marcel
Alex McCord and Caroline Manzo the
series taped earlier this year in
Morocco however production was briefly
halted due to a sexual assault claim
involving Brandy and Caroline Manzo it
was first reported that Brandy um and
Caroline were oh no Brandy was kicked
off due to unwanted kisses however page
six later exclusively reported that
Brandy had a largly touch Caroline's
breast area and vaginal area over her
clothes and then stuck her tongue down
her throat so Caroline has not said much
about the incident because it wasn't
good for her headspace but Brandy
proclaimed her innocence claiming that
she was set up she said it's BS and
Caroline was fine despite that Scandal
the installment was still set to air
however um another sexual lawsuit was
brought forward by a butler who appeared
on the franchise's second season and
leam mcweeny has a forthcoming
discrimination complaint set to be filed
uh against the network so an Insider is
saying real housewi Ultimate girls trip
Morocco was probably never going to air
and now they are thinking about tbling
Rooney Legacy as well NBC is really
pissed off because they feel like Bravo
let shed media the production company
ruined multiple shows Rooney obviously
being one many people appear to agree
with Camille that they still want this
season to air what do you think yeah I
mean obviously I don't watch Bravo that
intimately so again coming from a point
of view you that I don't have all the
information but I think to me this
sounds similar to like the bachelor
Reckoning from Bachelor in Paradise
where there's just way too much alcohol
involved and people are watching people
consume too much alcohol and do things
that they're not going to remember that
they're doing without intervening and I
do think that there probably needs to be
some sort of guideline something in
place I mean even in the Vanity Fair
article what I read from that was just
like you know people were so blackout so
hung over throwing up on themselves and
it's like inject yourself with the shot
gets an IV and keep it moving you know
and I feel like even though reality
TV is what it is it's entertaining and
it's all the things and whatnot there
still needs to be a responsibility from
these production companies to take care
of the talent like if people are
drinking too much like there's a reason
why bartenders cut you off like why is
in production cutting people off and I
think you know obviously I can't comment
on the Caroline Brandy situation I
wasn't there and it's two- sides St
story but I'm willing to 100% guess that
there's alcohol involved that both sides
have a different memory of what happened
probably maybe there's footage that
shows it maybe there isn't we also know
things are very heavily edited so I just
think there kind of has to be a little
bit of a Reckoning with reality TV
because while it's very entertaining and
and whatnot like a lot of lives have
also been ruined from reality TV you
know yeah and I'm not saying they
shouldn't air the show like I don't know
what they should do right because I
don't know what the footage looks like
and I don't really know what happened
but with all of these lawsuits against
Bravo there just has to be a moment
where they have to actually take it
seriously because to me the common
threat in a lot of this is that there's
just way too much alcohol involved and
like people are doing things behaving in
ways that they might not do when they're
sober or maybe they would and they
should not be on the show regardless
because they you know are extremely
inappropriate but regardless it's just
alcohol in those Mass consumptions right
like you're told to drink a lot so that
you can be funny and silly and do stupid
things and start fights and all the
things that people love about reality TV
but it has real life implications on
people yes but there's two
counterarguments one like you know the
entertainment value if some of the women
like when they're not drinking they're
not entertaining and there's no show
there so it's not like like there should
be other ways to you know conjure up an
entertaining show but like that's why I
think some of the women it's not just
production you know here pressuring them
it's them being like Oh I want to be
funny today like let me have a drink and
see what happens like or I'm feeling
nervous or I'm feeling anxious 100% the
other thing is like these are all
consenting adults who sign up for a
television show knowing that it could
make their career or it could break
their career and it's a risk that you
take these no one is forcing anyone to
be on these shows so agreed I totally
agree and yes it could ruin your life
but it could also make your life make
your that it's just a risk I just think
that if you see people are so visibly
drunk where they can't control
themselves a producer should step in and
put that person to bed I agree and also
as a watcher of these shows I can tell
you I don't find this that interesting
like it's it's not pleasant to watch and
it doesn't move the storyline forward
for me because it's like all null and
void the next day because that's not the
same person who it was the night before
so like I don't even find that very
interesting yeah no I totally hear that
and so I feel like there's a certain
amount of alcohol you know as like a
social lubricant get people comfortable
that is helpful towards making these
shows
but then it's harmful like anything else
it needs to be a balance yeah 100% I I
could not agree with you more great I'm
interested to see what happens here
because it's just too many lawsuits they
can't sweep it under the rug anymore
yeah but like I said to Claudia this
week I think I don't know that much will
happen because it's not there's not like
one person who can take the d The Fall
for this people would think it would be
Andy but he's been distancing himself
from being the boss of these shows for
years he always says oh you want this
house right back I'm not charge anymore
I don't do this I don't do that so it's
like he's been kind of preparing himself
for this moment and I just feel like
there's not going to be anyone who's
like held accountable because everyone
will just keep like right Bas on what
you're saying Bravo is already trying to
shed shed you know works for Bravo so
there's not going to be anyone who's
going to be um head on a spike for this
except for Ramona Singer like they fired
her from braavo Khan because of what
came out in the article and I feel like
they might just try and like put it Pin
It Off on her right and that's them you
know hey we're doing something well I
also wonder if like with things like
this it's a total domino effect right so
now that you start having people come
out like people are quiet for a really
long time because they're afraid and now
you're starting to see people not afraid
to speak anymore who knows how many more
other people are going to come out of
the woodwork yeah well I think it's hard
because like existing cast members
aren't going to bite the hands that feed
them former cast members just come off
disgruntled so yeah it's hard to find
like really credible yeah but there are
so many different shows and there have
been so many shows over the course of
time some that made it and some that
haven't and I agree with you it
definitely comes from a disgruntled lens
but the people that they spoke to it
doesn't come that come off that way to
me like when they spoke to Bethany who's
I don't know why she would be
disgruntled the show was really good for
her so if she's saying something like
it's worth listening to and then Leah
and Ebony I don't think are disgruntled
like they did their show it didn't work
out and now they're just sharing their
story agreed I totally agree so it's
hard to find like the right people who
people will be like hey you know listen
up maybe maybe there's more to the story
yeah well are you ready for our next
story sure um it's brought to you by
Quint I love highend luxury goods as
much as the next person but my wallet
isn't on the same page unfortunately
that was until I found Quin Quince is my
go-to place for luxury Essentials at
prices Within Reach Quin creates
Timeless Classics that never go out of
style you'll have them in your closet
forever quin's capsule wardrobe mus
haves like like 100% Mongolian Kashmir
sweaters from $50 washable silk tops and
dresses and flattering pants make
putting together any outfit that much
easier the best part all Quint items are
priced 50 to 80% less than similar
Brands by partnering directly with top
fabric factories for top quality fabric
Quin cuts out the cost of the middleman
and passes the savings on to us and Quin
only works with factories that use safe
ethical and responsible manufacturing
practices and premium fabrics and
finishes I love that I have gotten a
couple of gorgeous luxury items from
Quinn's but I don't have to pay that
luxury price tag but they it's like that
quiet Elegance understated look which is
all the rage right now and if you're
looking for pieces like that that are
going to be quality but not you know
screaming loud or not with a very Hefty
price tag Quint is the place to get it
so get affordable luxury with Quint go
to quince. toast for free shipping on
your order and 365 day returns that's qu
n c.com / toast to get free shipping and
365-day returns quinn.com toast 365 day
returns aming that's
wonderful now I also need to let you
know that the toast is brought to you by
Etsy hey there toast listeners it's the
holiday season so I want to talk to you
about Etsy if you're like me you're on a
mission to find handcrafted affordable
gifts made by independent sellers I love
finding gifts on Etsy because they are
so unique one of a kind thoughtful the
recipient always Lo loves them and
whether you're searching for custom home
pieces like cutting boards Linens throw
pillows for your favorite holiday hosts
or personalized items like purses
necklaces and seasonal jackets for your
most stylish family and friends Etsy has
it so one time I had a secret Santa for
someone and um I got someone who was in
college so I got them like custom
College merch from Etsy and they were
obsessed like you can just always find
the best gifts for someone on Etsy so if
you are shopping this holiday season for
your loved ones for stylish gifts home
gifts you can find amazing gifts on Etsy
I look forward to finding more gifts for
family and friends on Etsy and if I have
another Secret Santa this year you know
that's where I'm going so if you're new
to Etsy use the code holiday 10 for 10%
off your first purchase that's code
holiday 10 the maximum discount value of
$50 expires on December 31st 2023 see
terms at
etsy.com terms for handcrafted and
affordable gifts for everyone on your
list Etsy has it shop etsy.com for the
best
gifts our fourth story Disney will buy
full control of Hulu in a deal with
Comcast so a little movers and shakers
content news Disney has agreed to take
full control of Hulu in a deal with
Comcast which has owned a third of the
streamer ever since Disney's acquisition
of 21st Century Fox Entertainment assets
the acquisition of Comcast stake in Hulu
at fair market value will further Disney
streaming objectives said Bob Iger a
Securities filing confirmed that NBC
Universal triggered the purchase earlier
in the day saying we look forward to the
appraisal process and the determination
of Hulu's fair market value which we
expect will reflect the extraordinary
value of the business I absolutely need
to stop talking for a second so what do
you think about this I by the way I love
the way that you're reading
Comcast like literally so pronounced it
makes reading easier and that way I like
flub less words when I like say it weird
no it's great um this kind of goes back
to the freey of it all it's like okay so
now Disney is going to own Hulu it's
ESPN it's ABC so I pay for Hulu I pay
for Disney plus you know like sports ABC
cable like all of that it's like we just
have to get to a point where I can't be
paying for four different services that
are own all owned by the same company so
I'm wondering if the long-term play is
to bring it all together in one super
streaming app in a mechanis M such as
cable Yeah the more things change the
more they stay the same yeah just well
it's just the owner is different you
know yeah yeah but but that's really
what it is if it becomes like one
platform yeah well Disney plus just
raised their prices like it's just out
of control all the different content on
all the different places and now that
it's owned by the same people it needs
to all come together yeah I also didn't
realize that like Disney didn't own all
of Hulu and there was like a third and
third yeah Hulu has been weird like it
was owned by a lot of different people
Hulu's been stepping their [__] up
though I feel I love Hulu yeah what was
I just watching on no I I'm watching
lessons in chemistry on Apple TV plus
it's so good it's based on a book oh my
gosh I loved the book it was like the
best redheads book of last year and the
show is so good and they're releasing it
episodically so I just caught up and now
like I want more but it's like becoming
it's my comfort show at the moment yeah
I I watch Hulu all the time because all
the Shark Tank episodes go there um and
then they have like celebrity Family
Feud like they just have like a lot of
interesting things I mean the
Kardashians are on Hulu like Hulu is it
is legit you know yeah yeah they're
doing good stuff only murders which I
tried to start the new season but I just
it's weird but I watched it but I um I
just mentally like wasn't in the mood
for it but no shade to the show because
it's a good show yeah the thing about
only murders this season is just it
almost has like too much star power it
has like Merl street it's just like too
many people you know I think like when
you already have like the Martin Steve
Selena of it all you don't need there's
a Tina Fe and there like you just don't
need all those people I don't know I
can't explain it it's like almost
Overkill I understand that yeah but it
is um it's good it it actually took me a
little bit of a while to get through it
as well even though it's like only 10
short
episodes um but it was another one where
they like released week to week so that
was probably part of it because like I
didn't start it for a while I just don't
like when they do that again trying to
go back to the cable of it all to your
point it's like it it ain't broke don't
fix it then you tried to fix it and then
go back to what it was when you thought
it was broken did you watch tell me lies
on Hulu I did I loved that show yeah
another season coming for sure yeah I
just like I don't know why I like you
should also watch Cruel Summer if you
liked that also on Hulu Okay excellent
okay that's like what the kids are
watching I think so I'm certainly not a
kid so I do not know what you kind of we
they like like kid stuff like Jenny and
Georgia
I like jinny and Georgia because it's
just like you know top rated on Netflix
and then it shows up and I watch it and
it's good you wouldn't expect that like
Olivia watches chinny in Georgia really
yeah why it's just like it kind of has
that like drama crime component does it
I don't even know what it is oh yeah it
does did you watch um the summer I turn
pretty I watched the first season and
then I started the second and I watched
the first season just because everybody
was and I was like oh okay like let me
figure out what this is all about and I
thought the first season season was like
cute romcom drama and the second season
I didn't even get through the first
episode because it was so bad that's
exactly my been my experience too and
then Claudia said it so it wasn't even
like I know I could be like a Kagan
about like things that don't apply me uh
Claudia said it was bad too second
season so it's bad yeah no I try you
know I obviously watch a lot of TV and I
try to watch things that are
entertaining to me but for the most part
even if something's for the kids that
doesn't necessarily mean that it's bad
especially if it's like
yeah yeah yeah but like you just
wouldn't expect Olivia is like watching
like teeny bopper stuff but she what
other teeny bopper stuff like sex lives
of college girls I guess that's teeny
bopper but it's not yeah it's not it's
excellent yeah no I'm just saying like
it's just a fun fact about you like I
also watch a lot of things like you know
International crime you know things that
you know no that that's not teeny Boer
stuff no but because you watch those
things it's
surprising it's surprising that you also
incorporate teeny bism into your okay
what other teeny bism do I watch I don't
know
um no I don't really watch teeny boeris
I'm like I don't watch like Gilmore
Girls I guess it was just really cruel
summer and you like we're posting crol
summer because it was so good it's not
teeny Boer you should watch Pretty
Little Liars no see that I'm not ever
going to I'm not watching that I'm not
watching girls would like Pretty Little
Liars cuz you like teeny M and it's
you're so annoying and because it's like
crime no it's too cheesy cringe for me I
don't like stuff that's like in the
Supernatural like where it's like fake
it's it's not Supernatural okay it's
just a little farfetched I think but
it's it's not Supernatural yeah yeah
okay I'm not watching it just saying I
think you I think it would actually be
like perfect for you and you like Troy
and
Bellisario um I like her husband right
exactly yeah because he was in suits
right um yeah know I'm not into the
teenie bopper stuff I just like I watch
the trending things I would like to
frame it that way okay but Cruel Summer
like wasn't even trending was it no
that's why I I need to get off of you in
Cruel Summer because it's like Cloud
yeah because you can't think of one
other
example thank God you admitted it no no
I I think I already did but I know it
was just guess a shock that you like
were going so hard for Co summer you
should watch it and then you'll go hard
for it too that's fair yeah you could
you'll actually be the Claudia in the
moment of like having you know being
like being again something being so
stubborn top I think I said like
multiple times I should watch it but
agreed you should you should it's good
are you ready for a fifth and final
story I sure am a little light Fair
holiday flavor news o Eminem drops a new
vanilla and white chocolate flavor for
the holidays called toasty vanilla yummy
the holiday season has begun and M&M's
is really ready to celebrate Mars the
company behind the candy has released a
new toasty vanilla white chocolate M&M's
flavor that is coated in festive brown
white and vanilla crunchy candy shells
so new flavor M&M's what do you think
about M&M's always like remixing and
doing new flavors I like it but the the
one the ogs are still the best ones like
I live for a peanut &em and I live for
pretzel okay oh Pretzel's not OG though
I know but it's it's five plus years old
you know like the cookie crunch one they
have it's like not that great I like
love all of them like they have brownie
which is so good at like melts your mou
rich they have um what they have peanut
butter which isan but is amazing that's
a staple now they also I think they have
like a cold brew one I think um they
have caramel which again I caramel is
good I still think like peanut is one of
the best ones peanut and pretzel but I
do I pretzel is the best one agreed
agreed the best yeah and I this sounds
good chocolate can be hit or miss but I
love I'm like a vanilla flavored girly
so you know I'm into this into this too
I have High Hopes they should make like
um cookies and cream type like you know
those cookies and cream bars Hershey's
like they should make that M&M's yes do
you know that um one year um at like at
work I participated in a Halloween
what's it called um where you
have bracket Halloween candy bracket and
I had cookies and cream going all the
way and like I was shamed because it
really is the best but everyone like
went for Reese's cookies and cream is so
good but I do think it's like a little
bit divisive like some people like you
either love it or you don't like it but
then there are other candies that
everybody likes no I know but cookies
and cream is really the best especially
Frozen if you're looking for a sweet
treat this weekend I don't like frozen I
don't like my candies Frozen my husband
does that too I'm like why do I want to
break my tooth why no just good it's so
good cold and delicious it's good like
good good it's good room temperature
cookies and cream it's good room
temperature and delicious um I saw your
um midnight Milky Way right I was going
to say CL and I were having a
conversation about Halloween candy what
are your favorite Halloween candies like
what do you go for in the bowl um I'm
I've been going for the peanut M&M's
honestly like that's the vibe cuz a
little sweet cute packet I would never
go for the midnight Milky Way or the
Milky Way regardless I feel like I like
the Reese's Pieces The Peanut M&M's like
I like the things where there's multiple
yeah interesting you know what else is
really I do not like the sour gummy like
that my husband always gets the
chocolate bag and the sour gummy bags
from Costco and like that one and it's
not like I don't like nerds or Laffy
Taffy like I do it's just like I will
never freaking go for that you know I
like Laffy Taffy but it's just un oh
straight up you know what I'm obsessed
with Butterfinger I'm such a buttering I
was about to say we didn't talk about
Butterfinger when CLA and I were talking
but I love Butterfinger and like Keith
Bar toffee Vibes I'm obsessed is amazing
but it's niche like it's you know it's
not in I guess to the niche things and
I'm okay with that yeah like the
mainstream one Snickers Milky Way like
we're tired of you we're tired but I
think the Snickers ice cream bar is
delicious you just like frozen Candy I
do actually what do you think about
Twix solid but not the one I'm going for
it's the one I go for every time I have
like a stockpile of Twix did you
separate them out just for yourself so
no one could take them no the bowl is
still by my um it's in my foyer so like
when I go so much Halloween candy in my
pantry it's just like that's nice yeah
it is nice the kids really like we
hoarding you know like taking their two
hands and like digging into the bows
that's cute well that's your candy
update for the day and that is your
toast for the week Olivia thank you so
much for joining us last minute I hope
you enjoyed yourself I of course enjoyed
myself thank you so much for having me
and where can everyone follow you keep
up with you you can follow me at Olivia
ASR um predominantly on Instagram that
is my platform of choice I do not make
Tik toks and I'm sorry for that I just
um I'm a bit old um and that's the story
Morning Glory why don't you post your
food reels to Tik talk like you're
already making them I know it's just
like not like I feel like I don't have
Community there you know oo the
community yeah I love my community you
know I love my audience I love my
followers that's so nice yeah I'm not on
Tik Tok either so I was just I just feel
like there are different communities and
different places and like Tik Tok is not
where your people are my people are I do
feel that way personally I think that's
really fair so yeah even though I'm sure
there's a [__] ton of overlap with my
Instagram follower being on Tik Tok said
yeah thank you Instagram's Community
yeah greater than Tik Tok Community 100%
pass it on pass it on thank you guys so
much for listening to the toast I hope
everyone has a great weekend enjoy
yourselves stay safe do something
nourishing for the soul make a beef stew
see family call a loved one and we will
see you on Monday to celebrate my
birthday shabat Shalom love you
bye